das bleibt weiterhin die diskussion in
europa in deutschland wie locker dürfen
die korona maßnahmen nun sein und auch
der youtuber reso hat sich dazu zu wort
gemeldet und schimpft heftig vor allem
darüber dass schulen nun stück für stück
wieder eröffnet werden sollen er sagt
das sei zu gefährlich und nennt sein
neues video deshalb wie politiker
momentan aus schüler scheißen wir haben
einen diese politiker gefragt ob
tatsächlich auf das regime video
angesprochen
in dem angeblich die politiker auf
schüler scheißen mein kollege paul
ronzheimer hat mit niedersachsens
ministerpräsidenten stefan weih genau
darüber gesprochen
großes thema neben den öffnungen neben
den diskussionen um öffnungen das thema
schulen jetzt hat sich der blogger rieso
zu wort gemeldet und scharf kritisiert
dass abiturienten prüfungen in den
schulen machen müssen wie sehen sie
diese kritik von riese
ich glaube nicht dass sie berechtigt ist
das ist ein thema das die kultusminister
der 16 länder sehr sehr intensiv und
genau auch sehr verantwortungsvoll mit
gesprochenen haben wir wissen aus
ländern wie bei 130 meine hessen auch
die schon abiturprüfungen und der korona
bedingungen durchgeführt haben dass das
problemlos dort gelungen ist für
niedersachsen kann ich sagen wir haben
durch den übergang von acht auf neun
abiturienten jahre gerade in diesem jahr
statt der der gerade in diesem jahr
stattfindet auch deutlich weniger zahlen
an dieser stelle zu verzeichnen
also kleinere gruppen so dass sich das
wirklich für gut vertretbar halte
dennoch ist ja das ist ja die kritik von
riese in aller munde und das zitat das
sozusagen politiker darauf scheißen was
die sicherheit der schüler angeht
wie gehen sie damit um
also wissen sie vielleicht sollte man
sowieso mal die entsprechende
besprechung mit rein
abgesehen davon dass da andere worte
gewählt werden als wieso wurde er sich
davon überzeugen können dass alle leute
die derzeit an diesen themen arbeiten
erst mit einem maximum an
verantwortungsbewusstsein tun und es ist
leicht solche sprüche im studium oder
zuhause youtube beitrag film zu klopfen
und es ist nicht so leicht die
verantwortungsbewussten
abwägungsentscheidung vorzunehmen ich
würde ihn gerne einladen dann können bei
uns im krisenstab war sondern also zum
teilnehmen es ist ein urteil bilden
wenn sie ihnen dann ein laden in ihren
krisenstab
wieso was würden sie zu der kritik sagen
dass sich schüler anstecken können in
der schule und das daneben an ihre
eltern oder auch an ihre großeltern
weitergeben könnten den virus das virus
den sie dann gar nicht bemerkt haben und
so sozusagen ihre mitmenschen in gefahr
bringen also wir werden auch bis zu den
sommerferien kein normales schulleben
haben sondern die niedersachsen bringen
wir jedenfalls die die klassen sehr sehr
nach und nach wieder an dem stark und
niemals alle gleichzeitig denn wir
arbeiten nur mit geteilten klassen also
wenn sie sowohl schichtweise der wird
eine klasse geteilt die einen haben in
der einen woche 33 tage unterricht und
zwei tage war so dass einem home office
also elektronisches lernen zu hause in
der nächsten woche ist es umgekehrt so
dass wir es mit wesentlich kleineren
person zahlen zu tun haben und wir haben
für die einzelnen schule auch
entsprechend der hygiene konzepte also
alle beteiligten sind sich wirklich
ihrer verantwortung sehr bewusst
deswegen bin ich an dieser stelle
ziemlich gelassen ich bin sicher dass
wir mit dieser art und weise des
vorgehens unserer verantwortung gerecht
werden dass also die antwort von
ministerpräsidenten weil auf das youtube
video und auf die aussage von ressort
das die politiker momentan auf die
schüler scheiße
die schulen jetzt stück für stück wieder
eröffnet werden dürfen